yeah
good morning bachelor nation welcome
back to et live we're so excited for
another bachelorette breakdown I'm
Deidre Behar here with Katy crowd hey
guys and look at these gorgeous ladies
on our couch we've got Alexis waters and
Danielle oh yeah you're making it a
party for us this morning
thank you so much for being here you
guys we want to include you and
everything in our conversation we've got
an iPad we will get your comments
questions concerns if you have questions
for these lovely ladies send him to us
Katie and I will read them and we're
just gonna kick things off so Becca
episode 2 where your minds out are you
enjoying it are you bored how you
feeling no I loved last night's episode
like episode 2 and every season is like
so good yeah like last night I loved all
the dates I thought it was so and I
loved seeing Rachel Bryan back on t
works and then I loved the little jobs
day it was my favorite crazy
that's amazing she took her helmet off
there's like no sweat we're like we
would add sweat all over our faces like
we want to talk about the very first
incident that happened though and that's
photo gate generate we have Lincoln oh
yeah we have them fighting over this
picture that I guess Lincoln and Becca I
took and he's covered in cake and he
started crying I know over this I what
do you guys make of that situation well
I father like him that's like a bad sign
that he's getting like that angry over a
pitcher yes like that's a sight like
that's a not a good look so far like
jealousy like it was literally a picture
I know it's ago because I remember dlo
when she was on our season you guys were
in the newspaper you in there oh yeah
and everybody was like so pissed I'm
like oh my god it's literally like maybe
that's it really wasn't an acknowledge
if one of the girls on your season had
taken your newspaper clipping and threw
it into the pool or did some I think
they ripped it somebody ripped it yeah I
actually think so my dead ripped off
enter and then I think someone was like
oh yeah you know I don't remember but
either way it was just like I think like
that was also further on drew
the season when people is feeling type
develop more this was so early on blood
of glow let him have his moment whatever
it's just a picture to smash and then
thrown in pool
I felt like not only was it
disrespectful to Lincoln but tobacco
like Becca's in that picture to you
pretty much defile the picture oh that's
a great point that is a good point and
then also I mean but then he got like he
called it a doodle of Honor yeah Medal
of Honor I don't know to try and make
Connor look bad
yeah but then I think like when they
were back in the mansion and then he was
crying to everyone I was like I don't
know if I could take this seriously but
I mean I look you hit the nail on the
head
I mean this is someone who's potentially
your husband potentially the father of
your children if this is how Connor
handles being upset about a stupid
gimmicky photo imagine how he would
discipline a child I mean I gotta
speculate but like I just don't
appreciate the overt aggression handled
afterwards though like I like how he
brought a shirt and we don't like this
guy's the recovery was good yeah it was
great self-aware make mistakes in that
mansion I know that you guys I gotta go
crazy mind is like their self is getting
egged on by the other guys too here's
one you just actually did it I heard I
forgot who it was in the background but
he was like yeah get rid of the picture
yeah he just did what everyone else was
kind of thinking he's kind of weighing
into it yeah uncomfortable kind of weird
did you think Beckett was maybe gonna
send him home when she pulled him aside
I thought so cuz she was like I don't
want it this is like really early on and
it's like I don't like this sort of
aggression and bull yeah you know yeah
he wants a Blake that we were just
talking about the one I won oh my leg I
think he's a front-runner at this point
do you guys think I think he looks like
Johnny Manziel a little bit don't you
think
yeah I've heard miles teller - a little
miles teller no but I had to be like
yeah I love their day he was really cute
he's very authentic genuine sweet we've
liked how he was nervous
yeah he's nervous
I liked when he was like I just like how
happy she is like breaking all this and
then when they were on there first of
all they aren't Warwick I've never seen
more work yeah that's a restaurant it's
not a restaurant I've never seen
actually have seen it during the day for
work purposes
no Blake's Blake's the front runner so
far and like that makeout sesh I'm on
the wall I know do you buy beer
chemistry I felt like it was perhaps the
most like natural genuine connection
that Becca had last night
and then remember when he was talking
about like how he read I almost wanted
her to ask about that that like was he
snooping for that oh yeah I was
wondering the back story there and it
was only two months into the
relationship side he had a feeling like
something what's going on so I feel like
okay she was in the bathroom getting
ready her phone's going anyway but I
think he was just trying to like relate
it to like how fast the bachelor is and
like how fast he like is able to like
catch those yeah that's fair actually
nine point yeah but I do want to ask you
guys a question because this date the
the theme at the center of it was Ari
and I feel like last night there was Ari
in the first group date
there was Ari in the second group date
the the one-on-one date was completely
focused on Ari is the show giving too
much attention to Ari when Becca's whole
motive here is to move on yeah but I
think that that's what they do like
remember with like Becca Becca Joe Joe
they always refer back to back kind of
like yeah I always do that but I mean I
gotta like that yeah yeah just because
like I we I mean we're all rooting for
Becca so it's like we have to go back to
Ari and be like you were awful yeah so
smash that TV guy don't let us forget it
that little kid last night was like I
guess I guess Becca does know what she
signed up for I feel like maybe because
it's
only week two maybe as the season
progresses well yeah less and less of
that I mean my goodness nobody won't
ever see you an idea Ari sorry sorry I
always wanted justice for Becca - so by
having that date it's like let's just
tear [ __ ] up let's just sort all the
things what am I to do Ari and let's be
ready to move on we leave it in episode
2 yeah what do you guys make of Ari and
Lauren announcing their wedding date
right as this season was primary oh they
would days of that like the same week as
as the premiere so rude Wow yeah like
suspicious yeah you said that they did
it with like the purest of intentions
like we just want to get this news out
there we don't want to employ at least
they're not getting a televised right
nobody wants to say I'm happy of them
the announcement was not intimate the
wedding will be interview yeah yeah you
want to move on to group date numero dos
yes yes so the big shocker in group date
number two we actually have a clip of
Colton came to Beca with a pretty big
piece of information take a look
prior to coming onto this in January I
had a relationship with Tia and I wanted
to make sure to explain sort of that we
had a weekend together and we had a good
time but for me that timing wasn't right
to grow what was a spark into a flame
you know and if my feelings were strong
enough I wouldn't have came on this and
I think that what I know of you we could
build something awesome we could have
the time okay we'll get to that he went
on to the Bachelorette because he
thought it was gonna be Tia yeah kind of
course yeah I think that thoughts always
there and also they had a weekend
together but is he still a virgin
another great question
also if they only he claims that they
just spent a weekend together I've had a
good time what has had a good time man
yeah how involved were you if it was
just a casual weekend why I wouldn't go
up just I want to be like listen I spent
the weekend with somebody but I'm here
like I'm about to like raise men I see
you know later - yeah I think you guys
know what's going on right a little bit
like what can you tell us no I mean when
I get uncomfortable I just laugh cause I
just say you know I girl no I mean like
we had heard things that they had been
talking but we honestly don't know the
extent but then it was just like she
kind of found out that he went on The
Bachelor afterwards and like they were
talking and then so she did know like
they have not actually talked about him
going on The Bachelor cuz we see in next
week's episode that they do come face to
face yeah so I mean we're just gonna
have to wait yeah I'm sorry guys sorry
okay we'll leave it out one more
question do you guys think he has good
intentions he's a good guy yeah like why
we just try to reach out to like TIA
if he was going on to me you know you're
going on the show before like just like
I don't know like a month most people do
yeah but we don't know who the bachelor
was yeah so maybe thought it was Luke we
thought yeah I would have gone home
first night in that shark costume I mean
if he was dating her in real life what
and he liked her why would you sign up
for the bachelor well do you think he
was trying to up his chances by reaching
out to her cuz he thought she was gonna
be the Bachelorette yeah that's I think
that might be it
I mean come on yeah come on yeah
everyone was thinking it I don't think
we're like breaking anyone you know that
she kept them so yeah right she's given
him another chance and who will come
face to face with TIA next week I can't
wait that's gonna be to see another
person who's caused a lot of controversy
this season it is the male model it's
Jordan
we have some footage of him making his
impression on Becca at the cocktail
party last night his strategy was ditch
the clothes and I thought it was
interesting because the first episode he
was like oh I am mr. pocket square I
shot my stress dude in the room and now
he's kind of going for the complete
opposite he just wanted to show it all
off disrespectful did you find it funny
I thought no I I think he's just a
character at this point wants attention
whatever he was doing earlier wasn't
working and he's like you know what I'm
like this male model I'm just gonna take
all my clothes off and show my coat of
God do you feel like the bachelor plays
into these stereotypes I mean we have
Korean on our season and we have crystal
on her season and now we have Jordan and
they all kind of get grouped into this
over-the-top character caricature of
themselves in a way do you guys think
that's what's happening here or is he
being genuine I think he's genuine and I
think he's doing his wife feels that way
about himself I think it's kind of
entertaining to watch do you think he's
gonna get home watch these episodes and
be completely mortified because they
feel like being on a reality show is
holding up a mirror to yourself in a way
yeah what do you guys know I think like
he'll enjoy that well I think he loves
it I think that's what he went on to do
and I will I mean a model yeah he just
like visits like he's very pampered I
mean yeah yeah I really can't take him
serious but I don't think he's there for
to get pears not there for the right
reasons
yeah when you guys went on your show and
you watched it back what did you feel
I loved myself hey for honesty there but
like B I feel like you were very
authentic oh yeah I was just totally
myself so it was like just my friends
were watching it they were like I mean
this is just like hanging out with you
in real life I mean I'm normal I'm not
normal
I'm really goofy and I don't care what
people think and that's exactly like
what I had what I did is there any one
moment that if you could push rewind and
maybe do it differently you would uh
know whether on bachelor days yeah yeah
paradise
paradise yeah the scallop thing was like
taken way too at a contest like I mean
it was all so we were there half the
time then like it really was so like
they just went with they just took the
joke way too far yeah we're you shocked
on that edit there yeah I was this is
like a storyline Lily told the story
once and then it like was like brought
get like take it now she gets called
scallops and now I feel so bad I'm so
sorry God and I'm so pissed then I
thought you had to apologize to her
why you mean I felt bad I just really
told a story like of what happened like
we went the bungalow and she like took
like slap my finger it's over with like
scalloped fingers I was like bah like
what the hell I smile I just gotta take
it way too far I felt bad because she's
like now I'm gonna be called scout
shortly but I'm like oh my god scout
it is true how they can take such a
small thing and then they make yeah I
mean she knew like that she hit me with
scallops like a scout finger so like it
was just like another thing you're the
police yeah what about you I mean I sure
I'm back from paradise I wish things are
done differently I think I went into it
like halfway like laying the game when
relationships that already started and I
wish I just didn't listen to anyone
except myself like it's so hard like
getting advice I'm like your friends and
they're like what the producers are
telling you it's like I should have just
trusted my initial instinct and just
gone with that I'm curious the the
producers are telling you they're kind
of guiding you along are they
influencing the decisions that you're
making I mean I don't really think they
ever influenced it but I mean we're like
drinking we're not getting any sleep
we're not really eating it's like I
don't I just felt like I wasn't in a
very serious mindset when I got there
yeah and I was so like annoyed because
she's her alcohol like tolerance was
like she was getting drunk I was here
for so long that I was like community
like good tequila and I was like
literally doing you know like that
nothing's happening this is like I
should probably go home that was a great
decision yeah like you did really well
on you yeah I want to read some really
quick comments we're getting so many
Jaime says definitely Blake is a
frontrunner Natalie says they need to
stop bringing Ari up in every scene
Ari's
caged this is her time if she not over
him are they bringing him back for an
episode this is the stupidest season so
far and it's so played out
Natalie shots fired yeah Sephora says
favorite bachelor and bachelorette for
you guys well Rachel's my homegirl yeah
so we love her and bachelor I love Ben
yeah and he's like literally the nicest
man ever how do we find him love and I
love Caitlyn yeah and I know there's
like so hot yeah how do we find Ben love
would you guys ever would I know you
have a boyfriend right thinking guys
sorry no what'd I ever do but no but no
your friend Lauren yeah I'm yeah Laurens
really cool too
yeah I'm Lauren I feel like he is so
vocal about wanting to find love though
right even on bachelor Winter Games and
he was crying I feel like my heart was
just breaking he's a good guy thing well
good will happen
yeah he'll find a queen to be a nice
King yeah ginamarie says do you think
Jordan is there for the right reasons we
kind of just went over this probably not
that she loves you hey Jessica does it
guy love you it's so nice to have you by
my yes yeah I'm a no we're yeah explain
explain the backstory oh well I mean I
just want hoops like out of Dickens I
came out of the womb so I was like why
not like start selling them and make
everybody a part of hoop nation and like
it just gives me a sense of confidence
with every outfit I wear and then wit
CeeLo - how you feelin today I feel
amazing yeah this is a rose I wear hoops
all the time now yeah yeah yeah then
these are the Dallas's friends living in
Dallas yeah I love it
you're an entrepreneur I know I can we
want to hear about this new boyfriend we
hear that you are traveling a lot
yeah he's a lot of it he's the one I'm
tapped out yeah sorry ladies and
gentlemen I'm out of the game so how'd
you guys meet Oh Lindsay she dissed you
she's from Dallas oh she like introduced
me and like we just hit it off and we're
like complete opposite like I'm so loud
and annoying and he's just like very
sensitive and Mike
calm but like I'm the wild love I
thought need to be in that's good he
like is obsessed with me and I'm like
insane
well I loves it you know I mean yeah
well that's how you know the guy had
expired you see you're making
long-distance work yeah but I'm
basically always in Dallas as I started
my hoops out there so now I'm just like
always there are you gonna move I know
we're moving into the other I never
lived with a guy Bryan and Rachel well
we're always like never in dollars at
the same time but yes you're always in
Adam to Raven and Adam lives like
literally block away so like I skip down
the block
I'm so glad they're still together yeah
we're even on there yeah yeah I know
they're so cute I love Adam I have to
tell you I'm Ravens issues okay um I
just got engaged so I'm like in total
like wedding thank you mode I was just
gonna say is that a conversation that
you guys are having oh yeah yeah like
when don't see that happening probably
next year Wow
[Laughter]
safe to say you're probably not going
back on reality TV at least dating-wise
yeah dating-wise but you're down for
more reality TV Oh always yeah I mean I
like I'm killing with loops right now
I'm talking about a show I feel like so
many of you guys live in Dallas right
like cows Marge yeah they know Alice
housewives yeah it's happening how could
you do that because Jojo and Jordan are
also based in Dallas right yeah yeah I
have it I've never met her but like we
DM and stuff here and they're like I'm
so creepy I'm always like oh my god
you're so hot then but I never remember
but no yeah I would I'm a huge Bravo fan
so like but I like watching house I have
so much that I don't know if I would
want to be one I mean I'm even gonna ask
what am i talking no Cohen yes yes he's
sitting right here how do you think you
would do on housewives because I know
there's a little bit of cattiness on The
Bachelor but there's a lot of girls
lives
yeah but I feel like I'm not a big drama
gal so I don't know how I do but I feel
like I would be like Lisa Retta
you'd be like five yeah yeah but I need
to get married her so I need my wife
Danielle what about you nothing like
crazy anyway with no no no okay and
that's it's better that way yeah like
not having a public relationship okay so
no paradise for either of you guys no
not this year but we know some people
going but we need that yeah yeah I'm
excited because easy I think it's a
really good yeah yeah I'm excited I'm
hoping for grocery stores oh yeah
grocery job I love him so much I'm so
confused why he went home night one but
I think that they wanted him on paradise
probably yeah like they know it it
starts filming like now it's so crazy
like literally a year ago is when we
went yeah I feel like it's like years
ago I do have to ask you we were looking
Justin Bieber either like sideburns or
like liked your pictures I'm still
waiting for my D I'm Justin Bieber like
listen at all those all the girls nah my
Raven Raven mine who else I think I
think yeah What did he say
yeah he's a huge bachelor fan yes he saw
paradise yeah is he a bachelor fan
because it sounds like you guys really
sweet like yeah
[Laughter]
hangout in person how did you do no we
just I talked to him like a normal
person there are a lot of things in his
life recently and I feel like he
connected to people that were on
paradise that felt like they're going
through a while like oh he damn Dean -
oh yeah so did you consult like do you
guys like kind of event you're like
relationship issues tell me about life
and like things going you know he's very
connected to God right now so we talked
a lot about that it was really nice he's
in release weekend so was there a
bachelor party at his no I wasn't
invited yeah just go down you're
probably a dog Justin Bieber oh wow they
came over here I'm waiting for my deal
when was this right after paradise okay
and we're down was it ever wrong man
okay so you've not no no this is so
casual are you still in touch with
Justin Bieber I know
no I really know he's back with Lina
guys yeah we we are getting the wrap we
do have to do ask a couple more quick
questions how we're getting in trouble a
little bit okay you guys we know we know
you we met you both from Knicks season
what do you guys think of his acting
endeavors at the gym in Dallas and I saw
him on a so proper so Bob and I like
like tagging my tag him and everything
cuz I just always make fun of him and
then he like responded and I was like oh
my god yeah no I was like when your ex
is following you every you're just
trying to have a workout your ex's
follow you everywhere and it was like
sorry about that it was like oh I didn't
know you would spawn yeah but no part of
him turns yeah oh yeah I think me and
Nick have like a friendly relationship
like Moore's not really romantic which
was fine yeah that was good were you
guys surprised that he and Vanessa
didn't work out
know why he really wants to find I don't
think he was really confused yeah okay
in general yeah like why I think he's
just I just didn't think that like he
was in I don't think you they were ready
yeah I don't think he was ready him and
Dean and Jared do this I have to get
just that we're doing a parody I haven't
watched it yet but I'm sure I saw a nick
in a wig and I thought it was yeah yeah
I mean I think that's everything was
like really really what really really
really what he wanted to do and like
good Fred that's his choice then go
right ahead Nick I'll be sliding into
your dams in next project and then of
course Dean have you guys been in
contact at all
no I saw that Coachella know that what's
are you guys friendly on good turn
[Laughter]
Christine never had a chance to talk
we're all good friends and like it was
just I mean we're all really good
friends of CeeLo and then as well so we
like brought it back together I love
that we're gonna block you D Vegas for
asteroids birthday yeah noodling like
Kerry 9 yeah yeah that's that's really
what I mean sorry Dean you're out no
later on top anyways he has good taste
yeah they're both so hot is there
anything else before we wrap this party
maybe plug what you guys where people
can stay in touch with you and keep up
with you and what you're working on
yeah okay hoop nation by Alexis shop at
www.nadex.com and Alexis what is under
school okay Danielle Instagram and
Twitter I have a couple projects coming
up so stay tuned when are we gonna hear
about this new boyfriend oh I mean not
boyfriends Eddie like they're not know
him
now only likes my close friends I met
him yeah okay we're best single I find
out well you're kind of like lighting up
right now you seem really happy I'm glad
I mean general like okay good things
going on with my family I've been
traveling a lot I finally refurnished my
condo oh it is I've been lovely Minton I
have an apartment in a lie but I say
lady no to have a condo it is yeah I
finally feel like things are and she's
like king-size bed that's literally with
my problem right now I'm moving on like
hard like okay what are we capped you
have the sign of a good Bend though yeah
it is really comfortable sorry you guys
et was exclusively on set with Becca and
Blake on their one-on-one date it's
hilarious go to et online.com right now
to check it out keep up with these
ladies keep up with at Katy underscore
crafts oh yeah on Twitter right I'm
Deidre Behar bachelor nation we love you
have a good week
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]